I'm stunned by how many people look at  Twitter and just try to be funny and  don't realize that all the  characteristics that we like in people  are attractive on social networks you  know vulnerability is an attractive  trait empathy self-awareness kindness  there's a lot of ways to roll everybody  thinks that's snarky and witty Orly I'm  please trying to be more witty than the  next person on Twitter exhausting I'm  like this is ludicrous  you know the truth is you can get a lot  of value by being human you know  conversations the humanity of everything  is here because we're so close we're  just a screen away and the tone is  getting we're getting more and more used  to the tone you see people being less  confused by the tone on tweets and  emails I kind of look at some of that  data that's been interesting to me we're  actually forming into understanding the  tonality which is wild we're living  through interesting times yeah I think